good evening to you thank you for
joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez so a number of states
are still
in the very early stages of counting
votes which has led to lawsuits
and protests targeting election
departments two groups of president
trump supporters
gathered outside the department here in
clark county tonight with
different messages for leaders sasha
loftis joining us now from north las
vegas to fully explain
denise and brian good evening things
have calmed down here outside
election headquarters but things turned
tense and
hostile earlier this evening now the two
groups out here this morning were
chanting
their own messages the first stated that
president trump won the election and
cited a lack of transparency
from both media and election workers
it's important to note
the votes are still being counted as you
said here in nevada and all around the
country
now the second group focused on the
importance of ballot counting
itself they said while they are pro
president trump as well they were out
here tonight to make sure every single
person's vote
is included in this election now some
protesters even made references to
violence earlier saying they were going
to quote
take to the streets and purge though
they did
disperse about an hour or so ago and
things did remain
largely peaceful out here in north las
vegas
for now reporting live sasha loftis 8
news now